come
at 12 gmt november 15 2006. day one of a
new era in television news the al
jazeera media network expanded its reach
to the english-speaking audience and the
very first program live from our doha
news headquarters here the 24 hour
english language news channel has now
given a voice to the voiceless
the democratic republic of congo
al-jazeera english set out on a path
that was already semi-paved its sister
channel al jazeera arabic was already a
powerful regional brand with an
international outreach
the mission of al-jazeera english was to
build on that momentum which it did
in two years the new channel whose
initial aim was 20 million subscribers
was able to reach 80 million
its exclusive coverage of the israeli
war on gaza in 2008 made it stand out
among giant world competitors
with regional hubs in doha london
washington dc and kuala lumpur a vast
network of correspondents and social
media platforms it was able to provide
the most comprehensive news coverage
from the middle east africa asia europe
and the americas
the focus was on human stories this
meant taking risks reaching remote areas
and challenging government censorship
al jazeera championed the coverage of
what became known as the arab spring we
were really a platform for those who
were the euphoric crowds if you like in
squares across the arab world people who
were demanding freedom people who were
demanding democracy before their
struggle descended into armed conflict
we faced many many challenges over their
years by
while while covering conflicts in some
of the most troubled regions
while covering protests in egypt four
al-jazeera english journalists were
jailed on false charges for nearly two
years
the thing is we were doing our job as a
professional journalist in egypt and at
some point this did not
make the government in egypt happy they
didn't want anybody to report anything
but what do they see as the truth
so it was a shock people came arrest us
just simply for two reasons one they
don't want the truth to prevail for
people the second thing they wanted to
intimidate other foreign journalists or
journalists in general
undaunted that channel went ahead
gaining more popularity and winning
awards
it managed to reverse the direction of
the news flow giving a stronger voice to
the global south
[Music]
in 15 years al-jazeera english has
solidified its global footprint and
continues its commitment to viewers
by bringing to light stories that are
otherwise less covered
muhammad val al-jazeera
charles trendel is the managing director
of al jazeera english he says the range
and scope of the channel's coverage
distinguishes itself from other
international networks
we are a channel that is not based in a
traditional power center so we're not
from london we're not from washington
we're not from paris not from berlin or
we are we are in a region of the world
uh which isn't used to having you know
international news channels based there
and so by having by being based here uh
and along with our editorial perspective
which is to provide all perspectives and
alternative perspectives so that makes
it really important that i think al
jazeera english has such a wide range
and scope and depth in its coverage
unlike many other or most other news
organizations we've been doing voice of
the voice lists for
every day every hour every day for the
past 15 years coverage we've done on the
climate change and the cop some of the
packages from the field and earlier this
year as well about climate showing the
effects of
this climate emergency that we're going
through on everyday people and often
it's the most poor and marginalized
communities that are suffering and at
the front line of the climate change
some of those stories that we've done
among everything else
i think have been really powerful and
and telling the human story it's really
important that
we continue with the technological
revolution um and and wherever that's
going um and we're on the platforms that
provide our audiences what they need
but at the same time stick to the core
editorial values